how's it going bros my name is Oh what
the [ __ ] that is minecraft Oh bro that's
a [ __ ] sorry isn't it I was gonna say
I'm not sure if I'm on the right side of
the door and odd bright [ __ ] i was the
[ __ ] minecraft in my amnesia
hey so much in manually amnesia my
grandmother i have a pretty sweet memory
penis did I say that no of course I
think yeah I hate this bouncy boo-boo
bouncy boot really what all right uh
it's a good [ __ ]
loading [ __ ] is fun I always like
beginning with oh holy [ __ ] have a lot
of oil all right it's not a memory penis
I wouldn't make sure I mean I I love
memory penis penis [ __ ] man payment is
it's pretty sexy I was alone in my house
I'm just kidding
whip bounce all right oh god I don't
like this
wait hold on a second all right oh
please please at all let's go down here
anyway cuz why the [ __ ] not
hello anyone oh oh oh was it a [ __ ] oh
it was then pull vows bang both ah
goddammit poopers got damn I hate buffer
that all I'm dustbowl fell hey what is
this
woo think about ending what I do
hey I break [ __ ] I didn't mean to write
straight
ah here we go alright yep yep alright
and then this I'm sorry I didn't mean ah
oh yeah okay let's shake this up ice law
is a puzzle oh god puzzles wait can we
spin this
you've been I think I did something I
don't know here we go all right cool why
was hurt
all right initiate yes come on buddy
come on are there Matt doesn't work uh
all right let's spend some more oh okay
spend more you will spend my head right
round right round when you go down when
you go you / yeah Jesus
oh why are you doing this why are you
doing this to me why are you doing this
to me
are you doing this to me hi why why all
right um let's check if that I did
something here maybe go now I love that
look at that - it's a beautiful okay
let's go him here
close the door cuz I noticed you know
one Adam a new pot yeah painting Sonya
that makes you even less class welding
hey I'm surprised upon hasn't showed up
yet
hey there are no other doors right yeah
it's the only door mother good
what does that mean I've no idea
kind of weird ceiling I like it actually
it's not bad hey are there secrets here
at nicest I don't know what the door is
not good that should open oh right
alright let's pretend that didn't happen
all right
it's rock-throwing time Jennifer please
I didn't worry your dad yennefer you got
to me Matt rap-rap rap-rap
right alright work good job in fair okay
let's go
I have tested add-on so dark
oh let's not go there
oh [ __ ] Oh outdoor
[Music]
hi Bob now you turn it was proof rinette
and no it was stop door if you [ __ ] with
me one more time I swear to [ __ ] jam
it oh no I don't trust at door hi mother
penis
ha penny how you doing hello mr. Sherr I
knew it was preferred but I didn't tell
you you know why he's not my new friends
they actually treat me nice you're a
natural baby yeah fine whatever let's
look for more adventures now which way
this way Bob broke through we can be
friends we can be friends though I all
right I heard a - to me all right
let's ask I dunno an atom him though boy
don't [ __ ] with me - whoo yeah yeah jump
everywhere puppet demo activated [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right bang stairs just like in that
movie where she died bandha stairs oh
[ __ ] god I just going on here
all right maybe if you just sneak
I would love some [ __ ] lighting out
on that bad about him right now
stick up here oh [ __ ]
what is this happening you're not so bad
after all I'm so tough after all I mean
you think your top hat if you can ask
pity hat anything could have now you're
coming with me
you see there yep he doesn't see me huh
Darmok by your head mr. chair look this
is back I'm backing up
why can I go up here okay alright could
you go I thought it needed a key or
something all right let's go let's get
out of here
I don't trust this place it's locked
all right all I'm tables now so it's
cool
tables are friends they don't hurt dark
don't [ __ ] with me don't you dad if I
click me again uh-huh bookshops I love
me some book chair all right hey let's
get laid you yeah
wait chairs don't read what are you
doing miss Chan Danny
wait this isn't like correct why there's
something behind right yeah I found a
secret all right how do I do this maybe
there's a book at the pool you should be
uh oh I know I know I sneak here I'm a
[ __ ] ninja all right
what is this secret skin book some
reveal secrets let's see maybe if I
smash really [ __ ] hard okay try that
again
yes good books are actually useful after
all
I picked up it doesn't matter all right
I think don't think there is anything
else here anyway
okay hey Caramba is another thing okay
let's go back use the key to watch the
what I would assume it's this toy I know
don't [ __ ] wind mean door hate you
all right probably probably near
probably I'm just saying where did that
come from it it's here yes yeah I got it
I got door hey stop
really the doors hate me in this game
and there's mono at whatever oh she made
by flames and sea bass I know it
you [ __ ] trolls I will kill you
having scripting and dick hell's flames
three getting ideas and being raised to
Siva yeah that's the Sivas alright it
was super 13 and a personal measured
from Ziva bro bro bro bro bro bro bro
bro bro bro bro bro hope you liked it
bro I'm afraid bro bro see was very lazy
lazy partisan but you see that see watch
kenny there i really hope you like
scuttle story would put the I like train
socks Curtis I don't know if there's
copyright we can finish for the I like
train song I think I like range
and I see buzzes so [ __ ] lazy i I
feel bad for feelings for working with
anyway listen with this sign
anyway that was a couple stories I hope
you enjoyed I could favorite if you did
thanks for playing some achieve absolute
picking it and I'll see you later
[Music]
so many things salud should I really do
this I doubt there's anything to be
honest probably sounds super important
secret